does Jenna Ortega do her own stunts yes  I love to I give stunt coordinators such  immense anxiety I will throw myself on  the floor off a wall I'll drive cars at  90 to 100 miles per hour with stump  breaks that I've never used before in my  life why is Jenna Ortega in New Zealand  shooting that film X and I I was there  for maybe about three months I was only  in the North Island we shot in  Wellington I love that I I genuinely  would move there I love their  appreciation for their culture the Maori  people and how they make conscious  effort to keep it alive and also some of  the sweetest people I've ever met  there's people that I met during that  that short shoot that I I still am in  contact with to this day